i'm obviously incredibly excited about
the beauty and the beast
uh prequel series uh when and how you
co-executive producing co-writing you're
obviously very involved
when do you think that's going to be
filming and how many episodes are you
guys planning on doing
we're doing eight episodes uh it should
be
early next year uh we are in the midst
of um finishing the scripts right now
i can tell you that it is one of the
most ambitious projects i've ever been a
part of
um luke and i are so excited about
uh bringing these characters back to
life alongside a brilliant and
unique new talent in brianna middleton
uh playing this incredible new character
named tilly
and lisa tommy who's our director
is planning to do some unbelievably
ambitious things with this series
uh as well as um our show runners
adam and eddie who are uh i i
really really really going places i
think audiences are not
necessarily ready for it i cannot be
more excited about this show
i think it's going to be enormously
special